continued reaction on the breaking news
revealed and that Graham Grassley memo
released tonight let's go right to the
man in the middle of this storm house
Intel committee chair Devin Nunez
congressman your reaction to what we saw
tonight it is a vindication of what
we've been dealing with for the last
five days where we have been scolded
that the dossier really played no part
at all in the FISA application so
clearly that's not the case what people
are beginning to find out and you know
the sadly the mainstream media continues
to ignore this even tonight I was
looking no one's covering this but it's
amazing that the Democrats who were so
hot on exposing corruption in the in the
law enforcement all across this country
now it's like the FBI can do no wrong as
long as the ultimate goal is a removal
of Donald Trump you can never question
them if you do question them you're the
bad guy what has it been like for you
personally to be at the center of this
because you've been in this meat grinder
in the media I'm kind of used to it but
yeah I mean you really got thrown into
it as the house Intel committee chair
well the good thing was is that knowing
what happened earlier last year when we
exposed the unmasking that had occurred
and watching how they operated during
that time period I knew as we kept
building up to this by all the same
people who were attacking me that we had
the story nailed that we were a hundred
percent right and so it made it easy so
you know I said the other night that
it's actually enjoyable because you just
know that you're you've got the story I
always liked it when you when the
critics come after you I always wear it
as a badge of honor especially certain
critics like this watch is it possible
that the Republican chairman of the
House Intelligence is it possible if
they actually are Russian agents running
the house Intel Committee on the
Republican side III I hope that's not
the case I certainly have no information
to suggest that it is I think this is
this behavior speak of that though I
mean I'm not the first person who's
raised this mark Halperin's former
writing buddy so
that what about these outrageous
allegations because you're getting
hotter and hotter and hotter to the
truth you're getting closer and closer
and closer right and they turn up
they're turning up the heat on you as
you're getting closer to the truth about
what happened well and it's scary that
people actually would watch that and
then believe it right I mean we've been
Republicans for a long time especially
the House Intelligence Committee we were
begging the Obama administration to do
something about the Russia problem and
they ignored us I even said it was the
largest intelligence failure since 9/11
our failure to understand Putin and yet
the mainstream media doesn't care you
think they would actually call out some
of these guys who say this stuff but
they don't the facts don't get in the
way because I just think they they just
they do not want this president to be
successful and they don't want
Republicans to be successful and they
have one goal in mind and that is power
they just want Republicans removed from
the house of representing means
necessary by any means I mean look what
they did I mean it really appears like
you it with political dirt being moved
from a campaign being developed and paid
for by a campaign funneled right in the
FBI to open up an investigation into the
other campaign into the Trump campaign
and then to spy on someone is something
I would even I would never have imagined
this is where I knew about a year ago
well about a last March time frame that
the dossier was used in some form or
fashion but even at that time I thought
to myself I really have to be a minor
thing couldn't have been that crazy and
it ends up they were really that crazy
what about bringing back Comey mccabe
perhaps members of the State Department
of what we learned tonight and their
involvement in filing for this FISA
application knowing what they knew about
Christopher Steele even in the
subsequent applications he was
unreliable he had basically admitted as
such that he you know he had he was
getting sub sourced information
including from throughout the process
through Clinton associates are you gonna
bring people back yes oh so phase one of
the investigation was FISA abuse okay
and we closed that out in terms of what
we think members needed to know we're
moving on to the state to part
and irregularities there the next phase
will be looking at all the character
cast of characters and then conducting
those interviews State Department thus
far what can you tell us I can just tell
you that the State Department was
gathering information and then passing
it to very strange places that should
not have happened the Obama State
Department the Obama State Department I
will just say that there were comments
over the weekend from people within the
State Department that said John Kerry
had been briefed on the dossier that
they had provided the dose and the new
dossier whatever this new dossier is and
they had provided it also to the FBI so
by people starting to talk about it it
seems to me like some people may be
trying to distance themselves from the
rest of the cast of characters Lowenthal
longtime Clinton confidant he was trying
to push Hillary and emails to you know
policy to dump Qaddafi a lot of stuff
going on in Libya himself
Cody Shearer who was a longtime Clinton
you know hack who goes way back to the
mid-90s when I was you know covering all
this stuff back then there's a sense
that those two were involved in putting
information out there that got in the
hands of Christopher's steel can you
tell us anything about that well I will
have to tell you that you know we've
read a lot of the stories and but you
have to wait until we decide how we're
going to proceed with the investigation
I mean there's there's several people
involved Adam Schiff got punked I think
we have the call I want to play it she
got compromising materials on route
after their short relations okay what's
the nature of the compromise well there
were pictures of naked Trump okay and so
Putin was made aware of the availability
of the compromising material yes of
course okay well thank you very much we
will be back in touch with you through
our staff to make arrangements to obtain
these materials for our committee and
and for the FBI and and I appreciate
your reaching out to us congressman it
is not a never good
accents Russian accent I've lived it's
not a bad day it's a bad accent this is
really funny but well I look I think
it's pretty clear now you have the
Clinton campaign who was getting
information from the Russians dirt on
Trump and now you know that the House
Intelligence Committee Democrats were
getting dirt or attempting to get dirt
from Russians on Trump he's like take a
random phone call someone like it
whatever it got bring bring it to me
well I can remember that way back many
of the Democrats on the committee have
said that they have more than
circumstantial evidence that there was
collusion be trumping the Russians maybe
that was it you're very funny very funny
who said Devin newness is not funny it's
a straight man though it delivers it
straight thanks for being with us it's
always great to see